guy malandain bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
vous êtes le maire sortant divers gauche
de trappes élu depuis 2001 dans la ville
vous serez candidat pour un quatrième
mandat aux élections municipales premier
tour je le rappelle le 15 mars prochain
on précise que vous avez 82 ans pourquoi
être candidat pour un nouveau mandat est
d'abord là je ne rompt pas ce qui compte
c'est à mon avis c'est la fois
l'expérience
et puis le dévouement au service des
habitants et donc on va laisser la date
de naissance de côté pour l'instant ça
va très bien excellent engagement qui
compte alors moi je suis candidat avec
un certain nombre de mes amis d'autres
sont partis peu importe ce n'est pas le
seul objet parce que il ya d'abord
trappe et chacun le sait en tout cas les
habitants de trappes le savent ils
acceptent où ils risquent de te passer
c'est ma passion c'est voilà je je suis
tous les jours tous les jours pendant de
nombreuses heures au service des
habitants
parce que il y a dans cette ville des
éléments qu'on trouve pas ailleurs qui
sont des éléments de de fraternité de
rencontre des découpes de connaissances
voilà toutes les semaines je vais au
marché bonjour comment ça va si j'y vais
par des dames est pas venu qu'est ce qui
s'est passé bref un système de relations
humaines qui ne changent pas les choix
politiques on y viendra peut-être tout à
l'heure mais qui est pour moi quelque
chose de fondamental on n'est pas élu à
trappes vu la population qui est
exceptionnel je le dis contrairement à
ce qu'on raconte un peu partout
n'importe quoi merritt simplement que
les élus soit humainement attaché à un
travail ensemble à une promotion de la
ville et et à lui continué lui
construire l'avenir qu'on essaie de
bâtir avec les habitants quelles que
soient les difficultés mais qu'il faut
aussi avec avait beaucoup de plaisir de
ténacité et de réussite et vous
précisiez il ya un an au moment de
l'annoncé de votre candidature que voilà
si vous êtes réélu vous n'irez pas
forcément au bout de ce mandat est ce
que c'est toujours vrai aujourd'hui
c'est si vous êtes réélu
ne ferait pas forcément les six ans le
mandat on verra je dis souvent personne
ne sait qui est ce qui se passera demain
temps tant que je serai en forme
physique et intellectuelle et et qu' un
certain nombre de chantiers ne seront
pas terminés je veux pas mettre du temps
parce que j'en sais rien je serai
présent dans ma fonction
alors pour cette candidature vous avez
reçu le soutien du parti présidentiel de
la république en revanche est ce que ça
veut dire votre liste portera cette
couleur vous allez non au contraire
regardez votre indépendance celle d'un
homme de gauche vous êtes un ancien jeu
les spécialistes là s'excuse pourquoi le
le
notre député
nadia et et à la république mais je
précise aussi je veux pas m'ennuyer avec
ses propos mais c'est aussi quelqu'un de
trappes ses parents habitent toujours
trappe et cetera et cetera et avec un
certain nombre de ces la saison 2010 ils
ont analysé ce qu'on faisait alors
qu'elle tient dire à ses prétentions et
tout-venant c'est une réalité ils sont
venus ils analysent ce qu'on faisait et
hill on le pensait que soutenir l'action
éducative l'action sociale l'action
sportive l'action culturelle le
développement et ans dans la rénovation
urbaine qui a été fait en une étape et
qu'il va recommencer maintenant
bref que toute cette dynamique là
méritait un soutien et qu'on voulait et
là je le dis tout clair et convenait
bien à la dette
la députée donc je suis en les
sensibilités à gauche en tout cas moi je
vais pas changer les opinions je suis
entré en politique à gauche et j'ai
travaillé pendant des années je continue
à le faire et jean pierre chevènement il
s'est agi pour changer d'avis je t'ai
pas changé d'orientation nos choix
restent les mêmes mais il se fait que de
temps en temps le ce mouvement politique
a soutenu quelques maires de gauche pour
ce qu'ils faisaient et tant que ben
voila j'ai hérité de ce soutien alors
pas de nom de liste encore arrêté est ce
que le contenu en tout cas de la liste
est totalement athée ce que les membres
sont sont totalement connue elle est au
complet et réalise la plupart des des
membres sont des gens connus riz et dont
certains vont étonner
d'autres si je puis dire où on a conçu
les autres équipes moitié mortiers en
ancien moitié nouveaux seins si je puis
dire de iphone ça va renouveler avec des
personnalités qui sont dans l'esprit que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure on est engagé
pour les habitants pour la ville est
comme gelée mis dans ma lettre
d'intention
nous sommes ya pas de nom glisse mais
nous sommes la gauche qui fait qui
partira tout de même divisée attrape
avec cette candidature de l'australie
rabais ce qu est ce qu une alternance ça
ne m'intéresse pas et ne fait pas partie
des années côté c'est une partie de mes
comportements
pauli politique avec nous je dis
toujours et à la gauche s'y faire on
peut prouver ce qu'on a fait 1 et puis à
la gauche qui cause et qui prônait pas
si les gens croient aux promesses
passées leurs affaires vous êtes arrêté
de la municipalité je disais tout à
l'heure depuis 2001 quel bilan vous
dresser sur cette dernière mandature
celle qui s'est déroulée de 2014 à 2020
oui deux éléments essentiels vous pour
faire en perd trois roues liste à la
prévert comme on dit simplement bon pour
pour moi l'équipe a obtenu 2,2 deux
éléments positifs alors je répète
toujours un chacun à son jugement quand
on n'a rien fait c'est facile de juger
les autres c'est d'abord la poussée
éducative avec notre projet éducatif de
territoire on viendrait les 18 6 mai
dernier d'être d'être nommé avec le
label cité éducative
il ya des progrès et scolaires culturels
extérieurs tous les acteurs de manière
transversale
bien sûr le le passage de notre école de
musique en conservatoire ça veut dire
que les diplômes des des personnes dans
ce dans cette école dans ce
conservatoire maintenant sont d'une
valeur une valeur nationale
et puis enfin pour terminer ne pas être
trop long dessus est enfin le démarrage
des travaux sur la nationale 10 le mur
que vous avez ghislain sera lui au mois
d'avril en mauges et on met en place
encore dix ans et les services et les
entreprises nationales de l'équipement
on met en place le pont provisoire qui
va remplacer le pont le pont cachin ça
veut dire que ce projet dont on parle
depuis des dizaines dizaine d'années ça
y est les parties roulantes en vingt ans
de boulot on va voir laxisme dans les
c'est parti ces partis officiellement
partie et après on fait le rond-point rd
912 nationale 10 autre enjeu la
rénovation urbaine vous en parliez
est-ce que ça va se poursuivre il ya eu
la ville a profondément changé mineurs
le premier projet 350 millions d'euros
d'investissements plus une
transformation de la ville et enfin on
peut ne pas être d'accord ne peut pas
dire que la ville n'a pas changé et puis
là nous sommes en train de terminer les
négociations avec l agence nationale de
rénovation urbaine pour le deuxième
contrat de rénovation urbaine qui sera
beaucoup moins important que le produit
un thème qui revient constamment attrape
c'est la sécurité notamment la la
question de la radicalisation avec des
dizaines de départs vers la syrie skis
en mer a les moyens et ce qu'il a le
devoir d'agir et ce qu'il a les moyens
d'agir face à ce phénomène
alors deux réponses là dessus oui nous
avons vécu un moment douloureux
intensifs et qui s'est stoppée et nous
avons mis en place avec les services
compétents de l'état et ses terrains de
ça ne se fait pas oui en mer et ne peut
pas regarder ça sans bouger nous avons
mis en place différents outils bien le
mot convient peut-être pas enfin
différents éléments de travail pour
arrêter cesser ses départs vers la
violence la misère et d'inhumanité et là
nous sommes je moi je donne les
renseignements qu'on me donne
voilà nous sommes là maintenant revenu
en situation paisible par rapport à la
radicalisation à outrance qu'on a connu
un moment
dernière chose que vous avez des rendez
vous de campagne des rendez-vous prévu
avec la population les trappistes ans
dans les projets année prochaine cette
étude est celui de toute une série de
réunions à partir du 15 février oui
février merci à guy malandain
d'antalgiques vous êtes le maire va
divers gauche sortant de trappes
également vice président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et vous serez candidat pour un
quatrième mandat dans la commune se sont
officiellement déclarés aussi pour le
scrutin
othman nasri qui est conseiller
municipal d'opposition et qui mènera la
liste engagement trappe citoyens et
l'adjoint au maire ali rabais à la tête
de la liste pour que tu rappes respire